good evening um
i was not following the survey closely i
was getting nervous for the talk
if i understand correctly so 50 of the
people in the room sort of would prefer
not to have the second long dog
is that right
well i'll try to make it short
and
petra will actually uh guard me uh so
this is much less technical than
jeremy's talk and it's more about the
previous two years and uh my own
experience how i ended up developing a
simulation tool with
two ladies two programmers
that i think are one of the best
programmers i've ever met before one of
them is petra she's present here
another one is gabriela she will be
presented virtually in the talk as her
avatar
so um i'll mention her when her times
come and with a
group of uh uh other researchers uh from
the
b soap
that's the center for modeling and uh
of social and biological processes uh
together with petra uh we're from
chicago sciences
so
uh
this is the uh outline of my talk
uh so i'll i'll try in the first two
minutes
to tell the main message and then some
of the details there will actually be
some python code as well with
appropriate alert as uh but not much
so uh what is this uh this is actually
an agent a computer science talks about
agents a sort of abstract entity a piece
of software encapsulated
and situated in the environment
so the agents are
reacting to the environment through the
sensors and they are acting upon
producing actions and influencing the
environment so there's a an interesting
theory about agents that's part of a
computer science and one of the types of
an agent we like
is the agent with state so an agent that
has internal state some of you might be
familiar with finite state machines so
this is something like you put a finite
state machine into
an environment like aquarium or
something
right but the important thing is that
the agent uh remembers its state and the
state uh influences uh actions in the in
the future
so uh in uh multi-agent systems we are
interested in what happens if you have a
bunch of agents situated in the
environment interacting uh
among each other and with the
environment and this is actually a sort
of modern approach of modeling different
phenomena
we have multi-agent models in physics
where the agents can be particles
and the interesting thing what the
natural sciences and physics like to
observe is that you have a simple model
of the individuals the agents and some
complex behavior emerges like we've seen
the life these are cellular automata
right
i mean
very simple rules about how to behave
based on the neighborhood of your as a
cell and and we saw a slider running we
saw a slider gun producing the sliders
you can create uh logical uh
functions out of that right it's uh
turing
computable it's like
amazing so biologists like that too the
agents can be like some animals uh in an
ecological niche so uh
uh also in social sciences and economy
multi-agent systems or agent-based
models are really popular and we can
actually use them for epidemiological
modeling where the agents are humans
and they are interacting through
their connections by uh
social networks these can be your
personal contacts this can be your
friends on facebook and so on so these
connections can be of different types
a neighbor lover
somebody you met on a bus and so on and
so on
so in epidemics
modeling we are studying how uh an
infectious person can transmit the
disease uh
through the context and then what's the
degree of the epidemics uh
so yeah that's basically what what's the
talk is about and
now a couple of details
uh the epidemiological models to be fair
the first epidemiological model is
actually 100 years old and it's been
described by those differential
equations uh this is actually simple
you divide your
so think about some movies about zombie
apocalypse right so you divide your
population into three groups the one is
the infectious people that's the capital
i
uh
the one is uh healthy people but you
know these are medical doctors right so
healthy doesn't mean anything so they're
susceptible right waiting to be infected
and then you have recovered
that's the optimistic way how to
interpret the r
ah can be removed that's more of a
neutral term
so
and then the uh you have rates how to
shift from susceptible
to infectious by getting the disease
right so we have a perimeter beta that's
infection rate it depends on your
contacts with the uh possible infectious
people and uh some objective measures of
the infectiousness of the disease right
and then you have a recovery day rate
that can be viewed like one over gamma
means days of the infection how long
you're sick
and and then you're basically saying
well
on each day some part of people gets
from susceptible to infectious based on
the number of infectious people the uh
the ratio and
uh the uh divided by number of uh
population so there's nothing special
about this and actually we can program
it in python very easily so this is the
nerd alert
and now there's a python code
it's really simple you use scipy and
just the uh remember the formulas so you
just create a python function put some
of these parameters and then just code
uh call the uh integration uh
function from psi pi right and then
you're getting these uh nice uh curves
of infected people
uh recovered people susceptible people
so you can see
i mean that's pretty much an
epidemiological model
without good uh perimeters the the beta
the gamma without considering how they
are changing in time this is pretty much
the same as those like excel tables with
exponential functions that some of the
experts use at the beginning of the
of the pandemics so
yeah makes sense but uh there's a lot of
research how to assess the
exact values of those perimeters
well we have started our model basically
by extending this this uh sir model into
having more states but we're still
having an agent with states right so so
these are just detailed uh way how you
go through the the disease so forget
about this for now
and so you're susceptible
you can have false symptoms but let's
forget it
you're not getting uh
directly into infectious state but you
have the so-called exposed state where
you're having the disease but not
actually
having the symptoms and so on with the
symptoms it's also interesting because
you can have the covert disease by being
uh symptomatic or
asymptomatic so this is the asymptomatic
way
it usually ends in the optimistic r so
you recovered and then the symptomatic
way where you have some phase a couple
days being asymptomatic then symptomatic
and then uh either recovered or some
fatal cases as well
and uh so this is uh this is just a
finer
state model
uh to uh and the important thing is that
uh these depend on the perimeters of the
disease and maybe on your individual
perimeters either you are healthy really
so you're not getting symptoms your uh
your disease will last uh
less days and so on
but this part how to get from uh
being healthy to being exposed to get
the disease to get infected it actually
depends on the context of your context
so just briefly why do we have this
mirror of those states that are the same
as here but with the d these are
detected states and it reflects the sad
truth that we're not in reality we don't
know how many people
uh
is infected
on a certain day right we only know how
many people have been de detected to be
infected
and this might be 20
30
so that's why we have those and these
arrows actually means testing and uh
being proven to be infected
so we have some kind of observational
layer of a simulation here
this is what uh we get as the numbers
that are that were being published still
are but nobody's really interested now
and and this is the sort of objective
way like the objective numbers of
infected people exposed people and so on
we don't know about much about those
okay the state transitions in this
agents with states are interesting
because uh the the transitions going
from uh
exposed to infectious and then to
recovered are actually based on a data
uh from medical research so we have
those curves and they are uh basically
statistical distributions and in our
simulation we just
generate a random number for the
individual
based on this distribution and you see
these are not normal distributions for
example right and so there are
approximations based on real data but uh
but this allows us to have pretty
detailed model for those state
transitions
the only state transition we don't know
much about
let me go back
is this one
how you actually get infected right
okay
so for this we need the network of
context and
a good one
so we can study how contexts look like
according to the age this is a research
by
prem and colleagues and it shows age
groups uh and intensity of the context
between those age groups
so you see that that's sort of
interesting you see you're basically
meeting the people
your approximate age that's why we have
the dark diagonal then you have parents
with kids grandparents
with kids
those like darker areas
so this is sort of interesting but very
static
point of view on the context still
useful
uh
then you can have different contexts in
different environments so for the
epidemic modeling of respiratory disease
it is
important
to uh see if the contacts happen uh
within a family lots of contacts
school and work pretty uh quite a lot of
contacts visiting your friends pubs and
restaurants
not much of a shopping and services so
this is the division of context
according to the environment and it's
important because different environments
uh
are dangerous in different ways
if you're living with somebody
you have high chance to get infected if
you meet somebody on a public
bus you're probably
very unlikely to get
the
disease
a dynamic point of view how these
contexts change is this this is a
calendar of context from the beginning
of the uh epidemics till the end of the
first year and uh so from the research
you can actually see this was the
lockdown right we still remember
this so so the context drastically uh
uh fell down then in summer pretty much
the same level as before the pandemics
then another wave and other lockdowns
and personal uh uh
limitations in context
so this is interesting and for this uh
we were actually using uh the
the uh
peq research project uh
that's la live during pandemics uh and
they have
two uh
each two weeks they have questionaries
for groups of people and they gather the
information about the context so we know
uh different as we've seen here we know
different types of
but we can also break it down according
to the age of uh of the people and so on
so so this was invaluable source of
dynamics of the context
you can also use something like google
maps
application interface uh
that we're all also using for sort of
reality check if the uh research
actually makes sense
ah another python code i guess yeah
so uh
all these information about context of
people
can be expressed by the graph right for
the uh
prototype solution we actually use a
cool library called networkx
that i would recommend to everybody who
wants to work with graphs that's pretty
versatile
lots of graph algorithms the graphs are
cool you can put anything into the nodes
so here we have an example so you see we
have a node called romeo we have a node
called juliet
we're adding an edge
we have a bunch of notes about the
montec family we have a bunch of notes
of couple at family so you see that
we're creating a prototype model of
verona uh uh from the shakespeare play
and it it worked nicely so this is the
graph
uh you see romeo here and then this
montag family here uh we have juliet
here and couplettes here uh the the play
is actually beautiful it has 36
characters uh and we have everything we
have different families we have the
house of prince of verona
they have a super spreader event the
ball you remember right everybody who
means something in verona goes to the
ball that's a heaven for covet right
and we have different types of uh of
edges families and uh like work and so
on and so on so this was our prototype
model it worked very well uh
unfortunately when we moved to something
bigger like the model of a czech county
which we call the m town because at the
beginning we didn't want to tell the
truth that it's hodorine
because we wanted to test it on agents
but you know it can get personal right
our colleague joseph schlerker from uh
from the institute
actually says that uh
that uh epidemics is one of the
phenomena that we cannot test on people
i think he even said unfortunately
so but uh actually the different uh uh
different policies how different
countries actually dealt with the
pandemics were sort of some
you know tests on people and experiments
of people so now we have lots of
interesting data nevertheless we're
testing on agents but we need to create
a simulated czech county we decided for
houdini because it's relatively isolated
and a good size
now all of those jokes are about broom
tower right in czech so hordone is fine
it's uh
so we have uh
something like half of the people living
in the city of hodonin uh half of the
people living in neighboring villages uh
it's sort of a
what they call it a travel to work area
so we don't have that many exports and
imports that's why we haven't choose for
example what blondes go
because everybody goes to burnout every
day from blonde school
this
sixty thousand people resulted in uh
two and a half million of edges of those
contacts and they were divided into 30
layers uh representing families
schoolwork shops cafe restaurants public
transport and so on yeah we already
understand that and this actually showed
that
we have and this is gabriela
we were looking for somebody who is the
similar age as gabriella gabriela was
finishing her master's degree uh at the
beginning of the pandemics so out of the
simulated population we were looking for
a lady a student age 19 and we found one
in in the houdini uh so uh her name it
was uh
twenty nine thousand six nine one we uh
and the nickname is uh gabriella uh it
actually has an address so these are
like gps coordinates
it's not the real gabriella it's but
it's a real address in houdini
uh
she has uh more than 200 contacts like
young people are socially active they
have lots of contacts in schools and so
on and so on and we can actually study
what happens in gabriela uh during the
pandemics so this is why agent models
are good we have sort of a microscope we
can take how's gabriella doing oh she's
not alive in this world so let's run the
simulation again right
gabriela's doing good
unfortunately the network x that i
recommended before does not scale well
so for the size of verona having dozens
or hundreds of uh people and some
hundreds or thousands of edges is fine
but what we needed were more than two
million edges and all of a sudden we had
to re-engineer and uh that's a heroic
work of petra uh
that
we actually need to use sparse matrices
for the edge representation that sort of
makes sense
right a sparse matrix
because for 60 000 people you actually
have something like uh what three
billion
of possible edges that's a lot of edges
but we have only three million there so
we have one one thousandth of edges so
we represent
we represent the edges by sparse matrix
that's a csr matrix from psi pi i think
and then lots of numpy vectors and the
only point of doing this was really to
make it fast enough
so it boils down to have the edges
represented by a bunch of arrays vectors
that we can filter by boolean masks
so getting all the context of one person
is not that nice as before in networks x
so we have to filter use boolean filter
and the fancy indexing
slices of the of the vectors and then
doing dot products and stuff like that
uh
but we ended up to uh make it fast
i don't know a hundred times faster than
with networkx maybe even more so now we
can run the simulation in hodonin where
like one year of pandemics takes uh
minutes
to half an hour depending on the
complexity of the policies
so this is how the the code looks like
uh
we have this simulation engine that's
why i say highly optimized because it's
using numpy and for me it's sort of a
magic
runs on cluster uh we typically have to
run 100 simulations in one scenario to
get some statistical results uh
uh and then we have uh the data uh from
the points of interest uh uh like uh uh
schools uh shops
uh
uh
workplaces
uh so so we're collecting these data to
actually create the uh the graph
and some daily epidemic data
and weekly social data from the life
during pandemics
of course we need to have some expert
estimates for the parameters we have to
rely on those they were changing during
pandemics that was that's sort of
interesting because uh we had different
mutations but also you know the research
at the beginning we didn't know anything
so so the uh the research reports were
improving on the those perimeters
nevertheless
we found out that we still need some
kind of parameter fitting that's like
hyper perimeters uh
fitting in machine learning so that's
pretty much the same here so we're using
uh
methods from grid search to optimized uh
evolutionary strategies uh the
covariance matrix adaptation
evolutionary strategies that's sort of
highly optimized uh for finding a good
hyper-primitive fitting
so that's how the coat looks like and
now to get your flavor of the simulating
scenarios so this is one of the
interesting thing that was uh
uh
it was uh during the fall uh
uh 2020
where we were simulating what uh what
does it mean to uh do contract uh
contact restrictions so without a
contact restrictions you see that the uh
pandemics in hodonin well all those
results are for hordone right
so the pandemics in hodonin gets pretty
big and you can also see that we show
two graphs these are all infected
numbers so this should be the objective
number of infected people so at one day
we have six uh thousand infected people
so it's pretty much you know where like
all the hodonin gets gets it during uh
this one year
and this is the uh uh detected infected
so these are the numbers you can see in
the news right so when we're fitting the
model adjusting a bit of those
parameters we actually have to deal with
those detected numbers and these we are
getting a sort of uh the result of our
simulation they can be right
hopefully right
so that that's the problem that the
objective data is this right
another interesting scenario which we
can do because we have the layers of the
contacts
so we can say uh uh
if there is a contact tracing procedure
if you're infected you uh have an
interview uh with the uh people uh from
the hygienic service and uh
they ask you uh how many people uh you
met
last week right
and uh so people at the beginning people
were sort of honest but still they don't
remember any everything right so uh we
can actually say that we have categories
of contacts like family and you probably
remember who your wife is so if they ask
you if you met your wife in the last
week you probably be honest and tell
them
work and school usually
as well right
leisure and some other stuff like public
transportation pops probably not so
these categories can have different rate
of how many contacts you actually
tell them
that happened so we can think of
different contract tracing of
efficiencies like this vector for these
four categories one one one means ideal
you report everybody it's well it never
happens unless you have a smartphone
with some app that reports instead of
you and then you can be sort of uh
reporting family only for example right
you don't want to report your colleagues
from the work and so on and so on so we
were testing uh
again efficiency how we can beat the
epidemic wave
depending on this contact tracing
strategy so you see no tracing big
epidemy ideal tracing small epidemy but
the interesting thing is that
if if actually people report family
school and leisure
for example having some kind of uh
i don't know uh record trekking in
restaurants then were pretty much the
same as the ideal tracing so that's sort
of interesting family only sort of
middle type of
epidemics
back to gabriela
this is actually interesting i told you
that we can take a sort of a microscopic
level and observe what happens to
gabriella so we were doing the party
scenario the sort of super spreading
events and it's and these are like three
different scenarios and so it's
interesting that uh in one scenario uh
uh
she is exposed uh
she's actually getting infected but no
symptoms so uh
so after a couple days uh
she doesn't even know she has it in this
scenario right but she she was
infectious uh another scenario where uh
she has symptoms uh
uh she was detected by quarantine so
somebody reported her as a contact
because it was a big super spreader
event so she gets reported and uh go uh
uh go home right
so the quarantine was actually nicknamed
eva by another important member of our
team uh who was uh responsible for
starting the uh efficient quarantine
procedure uh
the first month
of the pandemics so eva was sort of a
strict
lady
good quarantine actually
so i mean the uh this was just to show
you how this can be used as a simulation
tool and in the last part i would like
to show you that you can actually use
the same approach change the graph
and
get also interesting results so we still
have the multi-agent system model
simulation and gene but
instead of using hordone graph we now
have a different graph of contacts and
this is a
research we did for the ministry of
education
because they were interested about the
efficiency of different measures in the
school environment
so
they actually took one school in prague
which is represented here
and uh
we had all the data about the school so
we had the uh
like number of uh
students in classes you know the the
schedules uh the teachers attending but
also the students and teachers filled
out a questionary about their other
context like who are their friends
with whom they share an office and so on
and so on so what we got uh is a graph
where we have
650 notes the students and teachers
and
we have more layers but the graph is
much smaller right so the layers
correspond to different classes and
contexts in the class out of the class
context in corridors
gyms cafeteria offices of the teachers
and so on
again different environments have a
different
level of
danger
and we use the same simulation engine
so here you see the uh the graph for the
teachers here you you can see the graph
for the students so you can see the
clusters represented uh by the classes
right and the goal for this was first i
mean can the hodonin engine run the
school environment and provide some
interesting results and we were
surprised it uh it can
and uh the the government was interested
in uh measures uh uh concerning the
partial closures like for example if
they close half of the classes uh
uh but allow the young kids to actually
go to the school because it's most
important for them uh about weekly
alternations if we uh if we you know do
weekly alternations yeah that's sort of
understandable uh and various testing
policies you remember the kids were
tested the teachers were tested so
do we need good tests or is it okay to
have some low quality tests how often
they should be tested and so on
and this actually uh showed the relative
efficiency
of uh different measures so first static
point of view and this is in czech i
apologize we see the number of infected
people uh uh that that this uh broken
down according to the environments so
this is in the class no wonder right
these people uh stay a lot of time in
the class out of the class nothing
special teacher teacher that's this not
that much teacher people more
uh
some amount of
of those activities afternoon activities
hobbies and so on uh
lots of for the launch
lots of further launch
so this is a static point of view from
the simulation
uh
cases in the environments
but we can also do uh
comparisons of different testing and
rotations alternations of the
uh
uh
in the school so what we have here is uh
this is basically closed school and
then
this is basically open school and in
between we have different uh strategies
like tests on mondays and thursdays with
shitty tests
tests on mondays and thursdays with good
tests and so on and this is uh tests and
weekly alternations so you can see that
basically if you combine weekly
alternations even with bad tests uh
you're getting very low levels of
epidemics in the school environment
so the testing however
annoying this might have been for the
for the for the people it actually it
was very efficient
because you're doing it often
right
and if you combine it with the weekly
alternations it uh
it lowers the level of pandemics a lot
of course this does not tell you about
the other problems that the students
have with the weekly alternations or
teachers but it just
can
tell you the
relative
importance of the measures so results
like that you can get from the
simulation and you're using the same
engine but different graph that's sort
of interesting
so
actually to conclude
we have created this model uh
it's on a github
so you can see it on epicity we have
different versions uh
of it and we're trying to make it from
the uh specialized model dependent on a
particular graph into more general tool
so now in epicity we have the hodonine
data we have the school data i just
presented and we have a couple like two
or three more graphs one representing
what is it lonely or something
yeah we have a colleague who lives in
loney so from some personal reasons we
created a model of lonely region as well
so
basically everybody can create if you
have some favorite village or you know
you can create a graph and uh play with
the epidemics there you can even name
the notes you know like gabriella or mr
novak
the unpleasant guy with the dog you know
and see what happens to him during the
pandemics so it's on github epicity
one thing these models are not very
useful for is the sort of global
pandemic situation reports and
predictions
so for this this is too microscopic you
know it's really good in uh
showing the efficiency of different
scenarios and sort of relative
comparison is it better to close the
bars is it better to close the schools
this model answers clearly for this
okay so the final nerd alert uh
uh this is a group
teamwork
so uh this uh
is really a uh effort of different
people from uh my colleagues petra and
gabriella
from the
computer science institute
uh to medical doctors like yantanka
mathematicians like rene lewinsky martin
schmidt uh and wheat to check
and programmers uh
sociologists like uh tomasz divak
epidemiologists like ludwig barrett's uh
there's lots of nerds involved in this
for the last two years
thank you for your attention
[Applause]
thank you everyone and we have some
questions on slido
so the first one
is according to your rule how efficient
or bad the correct restrictions were
injected
yeah well
it's recorded right
now
of course the first lockdown was really
severe right we didn't know what to
expect
and you you saw the restriction the
context the contacts were low you
remember it we were visiting maybe our
grandparents but maybe not even that
right the the life stopped so
this was i think an understandable
reaction to the situation but then uh in
the fall and then in spring
the uh the reactions were
too slow basically
so
i think that the problem of of the czech
republic version of uh
politics for the pandemics was that it
was uh
not in time
then it resulted in the situation being
bad for much longer
you know so the politics where you uh
where you react on the number of people
in hospitals
is really bad
because
people in a hospital
gets after two weeks of getting infected
so if you actually follow the
daily numbers of infected people
you have two week advance right
so
yeah of course a lockdown is
efficient
but it should come in time in a proper
time and if it comes earlier then
it can last
for
i don't know
weeks and not months
thank you now the related question is
about
how does it feel to know the truth and
see the decision makers not respecting
it
[Laughter]
well well uh well it has two parts so
the true
it's uh
it's very relative right the models at
the beginning were really bad and they
were improving and improving we didn't
know much the perimeters of the disease
were not right you know we had some
forecasts that were not exactly truth
that uh it helps that we were different
people you know with using different met
different methods and so everything went
through the check
of all those people so we were not in a
position of some other researchers that
were presenting their catastrophic
scenarios still we were presenting some
catastrophic scenarios and we were right
but
yeah sometimes it's frustrating
yeah
i hate going to the tv and being you
know the sad guy in black and telling
the best numbers
uh so i'm glad i'm not doing it anymore
thank you another question is is this uh
or another collect pandemic model rules
enough for predictions and thus usable
for restriction policies decisions
yeah
[Music]
not
yes
it's not good for predictions
uh
for predictions uh
the models that are better for
predictions are based on the traditional
equation based models but with a very
fine and sophisticated setting of the
hyper-perimeters
on the other hand this model is pretty
robust so we run it
every experiment we run 100 times or
1000 times and we do sensitivity
analysis and so on so
so the results are not just one random
experiment but there are statistically
sound and they are good for
assessing the efficiency of different
measures so relatively as i've said
before you can you can tell is it better
to close the schools or the bars or the
shops we can answer this
pretty certain
for forecasts not really
well maybe for forecasts in hodonine
exactly you know
thank you another question is more
technical it's about network x
so do you know why network x doesn't use
sparse matrix directly and could you
perhaps contribute that feature to
networks
i don't know why but their uh
their focus is on uh being very
user-friendly and general so it's more
like dictionaries you know and any kind
of data you can glue to the notes you
can glue to the edges well i can
actually imagine this can be done by
using sparse matrices as well but
well i love network x when i first saw
it i was like wow this is a beautiful uh
piece of python code you know it's
almost like mathematical you you write
your code and it looks like the
definitions what's the neighborhood of a
note you know
and so on so it's beautiful
maybe it can be done to use the sparse
matrices and scale better but the the
generality of the approach and the
interface is beautiful
thank you
another question is about
modeling the actual number of people who
died have you tried that when concrete
comparing data of deaths the previous
years
which is much much worse than reporting
uh yeah yeah we we when we match the the
the data the daily data during the
simulation we use whatever we can so uh
so we use the detected infected we use
the
debt people as well so so that's part of
matching uh the data
of the model to the data yeah so we're
using that yeah but we don't have any
global you know global theories about
that but in order for the model to
so we can tell the model performs good
uh the number of deceased people is
actually one of the important uh sort of
objective numbers
unfortunately the detected people they
they seem to be very objective but it
really depends on testing policies right
so for example if if you were forced to
to do the tests to go to the office for
example you have a nice sort of uniform
sampling of the population so the data
about the infections at that time are
pretty good
but
if you can avoid testing so lots of
people don't go there because they don't
have to and all of a sudden you don't
have an unbiased estimation of the data
so testing policies are one important
factor that makes uh the data more noisy
thank you sorry guys there are plenty of
questions in the queue but we have to
choose the last one because the time is
running out
so the last one is i didn't see a
reinfection edge in the state drive can
it support also that
reinfection wow yeah yeah uh we were not
considering this uh uh in this case but
uh
it's actually it's uh
not difficult to to have it in the model
because uh when you end up i just i just
show it well
there's lots of narratives i apologize
so uh when when you end up being uh
recovered you have some kind of rate
going going back here so that's sort of
easy and we actually did a specialized
research about reinfections
and
this is interesting we have uh
two papers one one is being published i
think and another is uh on the review
now and so we
have data about
reinfected people based on was it like
reinfection uh of which type or is it a
post-vaccination so uh we have a nice
model that that using this engine for
this special question like what are your
chances to getting uh infected after the
vaccination first though second dose the
booster or after reinfection after
infection previous infection as well so
there's different risks uh
and uh so it's an interesting
interesting piece of research uh we did
something in that i was just not
presenting it
okay thank you a lot
so one more approach
[Applause]
[Applause]